[Musique]
on ne regarde pas à la dépense
regardez ici on fait par et avec ça
qu'est bon vilain louis de funès
n'auront pas à ôter leur fond de teint
après le corniaud qui su battre plus un
record de recettes
voici nos deux héros une nouvelle fois
réunis il s'agit de la grande vadrouille
dans ce film au budget colossal plus
d'un milliards d'anciens francs
bourvil et peintre en bâtiment louis de
funès chef d'orchestre tous deux
l'action se déroule en 1942 fuit à
travers la france les armées
d'occupation
gérard oury signe la mise en scène on
vous a reproché à orry de faire des
films qui rapportent beaucoup d'argent
vous savez je crois que le cinéma et je
veux pas dire un produit parce que c'est
un en dépit du mot production que d'un
vilain mot mais une oeuvre qui est
destiné à la la plus large audience
mais à condition de ne pas donner à
cette large audience
un travail qui volent bas qui soit
médiocre qui soit peu ambitieux je crois
que le film comique en france a enfin
trouvé ses lettres de noblesse veut pas
dire spécialement avec le corniaud parce
qu'il ya eu de très grands films
comiques français et qu'il ya des
auteurs comiques en france aura tout de
même nous avons atteint avec le core duo
un but assez agréable et assez
appréciable est assez important pour mes
camarades cinéaste est un peu pour moi
même c'est que nous avons à la fois
touché une très très large audience et
que la critique dans son ensemble à
savoir ce qu'on appelle la jeune
critique et la critique classique ont
été extrêmement favorables au film ce
qui ne veut pas dire que car si on
connaissait la recette l'employons tout
ça ne veut absolument pas dire que le
sait le film suivant jouira des mêmes
avantages je dois même dire que un
succès important comme celui là bien au
contraire
est une contrainte pour moi pour moi
c'est une angoisse de savoir demi à mon
dieu j'ai les mêmes éléments est ce que
je vais refaire une oeuvre qui soit qui
soit valable
[Musique]